j'ouvre notre second débat avec cette
question faut-il interdire Tik Tok le
Sénat après plusieurs mois de travaux en
commission d'enquête recommande la
suspension du réseau social en France et
en Europe pour des risques je cite de
sécurité nationale de désinformation et
de santé psychologique des plus jeunes
Fabien Ricard c'est un ultimatum lancé à
TikTok les sénateurs demandent au
gouvernement de bannir le réseau social
si celui-ci ne donne pas des gages de
transparence d'ici le premier janvier
dans son rapport la commission d'enquête
dénonce l'opacité autour de Tik Tok et
en particulier de sa maison mère
dance hébergé aux îles Caïmans une
opacité qui cache une réalité le réseau
social est un féodé à Pékin c'est une
entreprise qui est techniquement
juridiquement capitalistiquement et
politiquement liés à la Chine qui
contrôle aussi bien les applications de
Tik Tok à l'intérieur de la Chine qu'à
l'interventionale par différents
mécanismes à partir du moment où l'État
chinois aujourd'hui c'est le Parti
communiste chinois cette application
cette plateforme par rapport aux autres
plateformes posent des problèmes
particuliers et notamment celui de voir
les données des utilisateurs siphonnés
au bénéfice du gouvernement chinois au
cours des auditions les représentants de
Tik Tok ont éludé toutes les questions
sur leur politique de confidentialité
face au risque d'espionnage certains
pays dont la France ont déjà interdit
l'application sur les téléphones
professionnels de leur fonctionnaires
les sénateurs demandent que soit élargi
cette interdiction le téléphone d'un
ministre ou le téléphone indirecteur
cabinet certes c'est important mais le
téléphone du chargé de la sécurité ou
des réseaux d'EDF ou de grandes
entreprises structurantes salées tout
autant pour pas dire plus dans certains
cas de figure donc nous proposons cette
élargissement en soi ce n'est pas bien
difficile à mettre en oeuvre mais en
fait ça traduit la volonté d'une
acculturation d'une prise de conscience
sur ce que sont les risques cyber un
danger qui se décline aussi sur le
terrain de la santé publique algorithme
ultra addictif mis en avant de contenu
sexualisés ou violents le Sénat dénonce
la nocivité de Tik Tok pour les plus
jeunes et par le même d'un risque
d'abrutissement en théorie interdite au
moins de 13 ans l'appli et pourtant
utilisé par 63% des petits français de
12 ans selon le rapport
faut-il interdire TikTok en débat avec
Claude malurey bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénateurs de l'Allier priant et
groupe les indépendants et rapporteurs
de cette commission d'enquête tip-toc à
mail Guiton bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste à Libération et spécialiste
des enjeux numérique j'accueille Nicolas
vanbremer je pense bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous président du cercle de
réflexion Renaissance numérique Mathieu
croissanto éditoris politique merci
Mathieu quelques chiffres tiens pour
commencer pour prendre conscience de du
de la puissance ou de l'influence
mondiale de TikTok niveau mondial le
réseau social le plus utilisé par les
quatre 18 ans il y passe en moyenne une
heure 47 par jour ça représente 150
millions d'utilisateurs en Europe et on
a ce chiffre d'un milliard 700 millions
d'abonnés dans le monde bon autour de
cette table on n'est pas vraiment cœur
de cible de TikTok
Claude malurey comment vous avez réagi
quand vous avez parcouru parce que pour
cette commission d'enquête vous êtes
allé sur TikTok vous avez regardé je
vous demande pas les le résultat la
commission d'enquête tout de suite mais
votre première réaction sur le contenu
quand vous êtes vous avez vu le contenu
de ce réseau social qu'est-ce que vous
vous êtes dit je crois que vous avez
raison on n'est pas vraiment le public
en contenu m'a pas particulièrement ni
intéressé ni choquer c'est un contenu
bébé j'ai à peu près la même réaction
que le Président de la République je
crois qu'il dise une naïveté confondante
voilà vous passez votre temps à faire à
scroller et à faire défiler des des
petites vidéos
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous en
dise et il a le conduit en tant que tel
et puis là comme tous les autres sociaux
les potentialité évidemment quand on est
quand on a une addiction de tout ce
qu'il y a sur les autres les fake news
la haine en ligne le harcèlement etc
mais quand on scrol comme ça et qu'on le
regarde on le voit pas du premier coup
ça peut sembler anodin et c'est en ça
que c'est aussi intéressant on y
reviendra à malguiton c'est une
croissance quand même qui est rapide ou
ultra rapide en combien d'années toc
atteint-il cette cette audience et puis
surtout pourquoi ça marche est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer
l'application elle-même a été créée en
2016 on est je crois on est de toute
façon à plus d'un milliard je crois aux
alentours d'un milliard 7 utilisateurs
d'utilisateurs mondiaux donc
effectivement ça ça fonctionne très bien
c'est une croissance très forte c'est
surtout ce qui est surtout assez
étonnant et c'est une première c'est que
c'est un réseau social effectivement
qui a été créé par une entreprise
chinoise mais qui pour le coup prend à
l'international ce qu'on n'avait pas vu
jusqu'à maintenant c'est-à-dire qu'il y
avait des réseaux sociaux en Chine comme
il y a des réseaux sociaux en Russie
mais qui n'avaient pas à ce point mordu
donc là il y a quelque chose
effectivement de d'assez inédit alors
après pourquoi ça marche bah parce que
manifestement ça correspond à une
demande parce que ce sont des formats
très courts et parce que ils sont
effectivement très très bons semble-t-il
en profilage aussi des utilisateurs et
en capacité en fait entre guillemets à
leur servir ce qu'ils ont envie de voir
donc c'est ça je pense que ça correspond
à la fois à des à des usages et
effectivement à une capacité à trouver à
trouver une audience
sur pas mal de réseaux sociaux ce risque
d'enfermement c'est sur multiplier par
TikTok est-ce que vous diriez ça je
surmultiplier je sais pas si j'irai
jusque là moi en fait j'ai l'impression
et d'ailleurs on y reviendra sans doute
au cours de la discussion mais j'ai
l'impression d'une certaine façon TikTok
pousse encore plus loin tous les
problèmes qu'on pouvait déjà relever sur
les autres la question effectivement de
la gourmandise en donnée la question du
profilage des utilisateurs la question
de l'accès des autorités etc c'est on
est au cran d'après mais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il y ait de
véritablement de de nouveautés à part
peut-être effectivement un usage de
l'intelligence artificielle qui me
semble peut-être plus développé
qu'ailleurs et alors notamment en
matière de de modération c'est parce
qu'ils disent là récemment qu'ils ont
renforcé à leurs équipes de modération
humaine mais on a quand même le
sentiment que ça surtout jusqu'à
maintenant reposer sur de la modération
algorithmique
filiale du groupe chinois je sais pas
comment prononce bike Dante sous bid
dance c'est quoi c'est un groupe très
puissant qu'est-ce que ça représente ce
groupe si on le compare à d'autres à
d'autres géants d'Internet par exemple
on ne sait pas exactement c'est un des
employés pour la première fois le mot
opacité dans ce dans ce débat
ouais ouais alors moi je suis dans le
dans le détail de la structure etc j'ai
pas fait la commission d'enquête et je
pense qu'il y a des sujets qui sont pas
d'une clarté totale mais oui on parle
d'un groupe qui est assez costaud qui je
pensais plutôt comparable en taille à
méta que que
met à l'ancien Facebook Instagram ça un
peu plus petit quand même a priori mais
en terme de nombre d'utilisateurs c'est
c'est très comparable voilà on change en
surface financière etc bah oui on a
moins de c'est pas une boîte de côté en
bourse au Nasdaq qui fait de la
lisibilité partout donc évidemment on a
on n'a pas tellement cette habitude là
quoi donc il y a plus d'opacité
effectivement au moins de lisibilité en
la matière quoi mais c'est vraiment
quelque chose
de nouveau je pense que c'est moins un
réseau social c'est vraiment plus un
média contributif mais la dimension
sociale d'interaction entre individus
est très beaucoup moins présente dans
Tik Tok et dans sa nature c'est quoi
c'est un partage de vidéo très courtois
voilà on va consommer du contenu c'est
beaucoup plus un média d'accord qu'un
réseau social entre les personnes qui
l'alimente le média les utilisateurs par
des utilisateurs mais pas pas de manière
égale pas du tout de manière égale c'est
vraiment on va vraiment consommer des
contenus chacun peut participer on peut
avoir une capacité de propulsion des
contenus qui est énorme avec comme ça un
algorithme qui les fait monter et qui va
chercher le succès des contenus voilà
donc pour chacun c'est assez intéressant
mais on est vraiment sur quelque chose
qui a poussé très très loin l'algorithme
au cœur versus la relation entre
individu et ça je pense que c'est
effectivement un changement de nature
qui est un chemin que prennent les
réseaux sociaux mais qui est un proche
alors on va détailler les principales
conclusions de de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat Claude malloret
l'argument principal pour justifier une
sus de Tik Tok puisque c'est la
perspective dans laquelle vous vous
placez en France et en Europe c'est quoi
ces liens avec le pouvoir chinois avec
la Chine alors d'abord on n'est pas on
n'est pas là pour brandir le gourdin
pour interdire pour supprimer pour pour
suspendre c'est pas notre but
je voudrais surtout pas que cette mesure
qui fait partie des des propositions
soit considérées comme le taux ou rien
de la de la commission ce qu'on lui ont
dit c'est que aujourd'hui Tik Tok refuse
et maintenant il y a quand même quelques
années d'existence on refuse
pratiquement toutes les demandes de ce
qu'ils appellent le rgpd le règlement
des données publiques de ce qui
s'appelle le DSA c'est à dire le niveau
la protection des données au niveau
européen
refuge des étoiles ces actes de refusent
de donner
les renseignements que l'art comme
demande à toutes les plateformes le
tableau est de l'arcom est et Pharaon
vous avez un tableau de trois pages avec
tel point pas de réponse tel point pas
de réponse c'est le point pas avant les
autres les autres applications répondent
les autres plateformes répondent plus ou
moins mais réponds tiklock se fout du
monde je crois qu'on peut pas dire
autrement et puis le troisième le
troisième point effectivement c'est la
dictativité la dictée terrible de
l'algorithme et en plus une addictivité
renforcée parce qu'il s'appelle le
eating le poussage les pousseurs et puis
le Shadow banning c'est-à-dire vous vous
écrasez les vidéos de certains
contributeurs et vous faites monder donc
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est une autre façon de fonctionner
mais ça donne beaucoup plus de puissance
centrale je dirais à l'application qui
peut faire monter ou faire descendre les
les ce qu'elle veut donc la suspension
elle consiste à dire vous deux si tu
répondais pas il y a des demandes
obligatoires et le DSA va être en
pratique le 24 août prochain dans un
mois si vous continuez à ne pas y
répondre à ce moment-là il y a qu'une
solution c'est la suivante suspension ne
veut pas dire interdiction ça veut dire
justement jusqu'à ce que vous répondu
donc on n'avait pas là pour faire les
flics mais on est là pour dire la
naïveté des Européens ça suffit d'accord
Mathieu c'était obligatoire déjà depuis
quelques années oui mais ça n'est pas
mais ça n'est juste c'est obligatoire
mais quand vous dites qu'il peut les
faire changer d'avis pourquoi il
changeait quand vous avez des
régulateurs comme la CNIL a des
possibilités de sanctions comme vous
avez des régulateurs et encore plus dans
certains pays européens qui n'ont pas
les moyens de sanctionner qui n'ont ou
quand elles sanctionnées mais ça serait
une voiture qui respecterait pas les
normes européennes ou les normes
françaises de sécurité vous interdire
cette voiture là vous êtes législateur
vous dites pas en interdittre réseau qui
ne coche pas les cases et qui ne répond
pas aux normes qu'on a fixé nous dans
notre pays et qui ne correspond pas non
plus aux normes qu'on a fixé en Europe
mais c'est bien ce qu'on dit il ne
respecte pas parce que moi j'ai pas les
moyens je suis législateur seul les
gouvernements et en fait avec le vote du
DSA seul la Commission européenne
aujourd'hui pourra décider de l'Internet
la France on peut décider d'elle-même
alors elle peut sans doute par exemple
vous avez déjà une loi qui permet en cas
de perte pédopornographie ou de
terrorisme de suspendre la mais il faut
quand même que ce soit des des des
choses leur graves il y a eu des
interdictions déjà aux États-Unis par
exemple l'état du Montana je crois était
le premier à interdire le réseau Tik Tok
donc alors d'ailleurs il y a des
plaintes qui sont il y a des plaintes
qui sont sont suivis plein de financés
par qui par Tic-Toc bon voilà c'est
intéressant de voir le bras de fer jury
qui va commencer à être aller aussi loin
on a des interdictions effectivement en
Inde au Pakistan en Afghanistan dans un
certain nombre de pays assez restreints
dans les pays occidentaux on est plutôt
sur
quelque chose d'un peu à mi-chemin qui
consiste à dire les téléphones
professionnels des agents de l'État il
doit pas y avoir TikTok dessus alors il
y a des pays où c'est interdiction ne
visent que TikTok il y a des pays dont
la France ou cette interdiction s'étend
à l'ensemble des applications dites
récréatives et oui et en tout cas au
grand réseau sociaux parce qu'on
considère donc effectivement il peut y
avoir aussi un moment donné des enjeux
entre guillemets de sécurité nationale
mais l'interdiction pure est simple
c'est pas la même chose d'interdire un
contenu de retirer un contenu ou
d'interdire un réseau social à plus d'un
milliard d'utilisateurs plus compliqué
sachant que
si TikTok est peut être vu effectivement
à la lecture du rapport de la commission
d'enquête comme un très mauvais élève on
peut pas non plus oublier qu'en matière
d'application du règlement général de
sur la protection des données européen
il y a aussi des grands réseaux sociaux
américains qui ont un certain nombre
d'affaires pendant devant des
régulateurs type CNIL voire devant des
juridictions européennes donc il y a
aussi il y a aussi cet aspect là c'est à
dire que si on ouvre
pour faire appliquer nos propres
règlements
intervenir
j'insiste enfin j'ai ainsi ce réseau il
ne répond pas aux normes sur la question
des données personnelles il est
tellement addictif que de ce que j'ai
compris la Chine n'interdit à ses
propres enfants au delà du Nord par jour
15 minutes et nous on dit ben non c'est
compliqué enfin je comprends pas les
règles d'un état de droit c'est c'est
aussi ça en fait
l'interdit bah oui c'était effectivement
un autoritaire ou Simpson peut dire bah
moi j'interdis de faire ceci j'intervie
de faire ça je rappelle que c'est un
réseau chinois donc c'était c'est
savoureux
mais effectivement le l'espace n'est pas
aussi libre passe une période n'est pas
aussi libre en Chine qu'il est qu'il est
en France et en Europe nous on a des
règles on a des règles on a des
contentieux qui sont possibles qui sont
lancés on a les régulateurs et qui ont
été lancés
et qu'on ne fait pas
appliquera c'est-à-dire qu'on est en
France le pays qui a impulsé une
réglementation européenne qui s'appelle
le Règlement sur les services numériques
donc j'imagine on a souvent parlé sur ce
plateau qui est en train d'arriver en
place et qui va imposer sur beaucoup des
éléments qui sont mis dans le rapport
une une exigence accrue très forte
de thèmes de sous thème en quelque sorte
non pas du tout c'est très intéressant
et je vous suis mais là je voudrais
quand même parce qu'on n'a pas tout à
fait répondu à la question des liens
entre Tik Tok et le pouvoir chinois ou
le Parti communiste chinois je vous
propose un témoignage à celui de Marc
Fadoul qui chercheur en intelligence
artificielle qui était auditionné par la
commission d'enquête c'était au mois de
mars et Couton alors après bien sûr il y
a des critiques spécifiques à Tik Tok
notamment liées à l'origine chinoise de
l'entreprise et les liens que cela
suppose nécessairement avec le Parti
communiste chinois
des documents ayant fuité en 2020
montrent qu'à une époque les modérateurs
de plateformes de la plateforme avaient
pour instruction de censurer certains
thèmes politiques sensibles pour le
Parti communiste chinois notamment ceux
qui faisaient référence aux
manifestations de la place Tian'anmen
la Chine d'oxygin a aussi montré à
plusieurs reprises quel contrôlait
l'écosystème technologique avec une main
de fer donc là on est sur des cas de
censurge et une autre question Claude
malurey est-ce qu'on a des preuves de
cas d'espionnage de personnalités de
journalistes de personnalités politiques
je ne sais ou de transfert de données
via ce réseau Tic-Toc moi on a employé
le terme c'est d'ailleurs notre titre
cheval de Troie de la Chine qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez dire là-dessus
on a des preuves TikTok dit toujours
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai c'est vrai
jusqu'au moment où on amène l'épreuve et
à ce moment-là ils reviennent déjà ben
oui effectivement là c'est vrai mais on
va sanctionner ce qu'ils l'ont fait
c'était pas du tout dans notre politique
et on s'engage à ne plus le faire mais
si on les transferts de données il y a
évidemment il y a des preuves il y a les
80 mails sur leur messagerie interne qui
ont été hackées et qui ont permis à une
enquête journalistique américaine de
montrer et notamment parmi ces mails il
y en a un qui dit qui vient d'un des
ingénieurs chinois à Pékin mais qui dit
été vu en Chine tout est vu il dit pas
on envoie tout est vu donc vous avez
vous avez aussi l'espionnage de
journalistes américains qui enquêtait
sur Tik Tok et notamment de formes donc
une très très grand journal américain
qui se sont fait espionner qui se
recherche
donc ceci c'est c'est prouvé et encore
c'est prouvé avec toutes les difficultés
que vous imaginez parce que tout est le
pack tout est fait tout est fait en
Chine et tout et vous avez pas les
moyens d'enquête donc de temps en temps
ça sort donc de ce point-là c'est prouvé
la deuxième problème c'est que pour
faire croire que les deux sociétés et la
société chinoise qui s'appelle Douilly
et la société TikTok mais qui sont
exactement les mêmes qui sont des
filiales de Biden et qui ont été créés
toutes au même à peu près au même moment
et il vous disent toujours vous vous
pouvez voir dans la commission enquête
dans le rapport les personnes
responsabilités au conditionnées que
vous disent ça n'a rien à voir rien à
voir c'est complètement différent etc en
fait d'une part l'algorithme et le même
et il est prouvé d'ailleurs il l'a
reconnu dans la commission d'enquête
qu'il travaille à eux que dit coque
France comme tik Toky UK etc travaille
avec des avec l'algorithme qui est
gérait et amélioré par des ingénieurs
chinois en Chine troisièmement la loi
chinoise prévoit aujourd'hui à que
toutes les entreprises que vous vendiez
des robinets ou que vous soyez une
plateforme vous devez en référer aux
parties communistes au service de
renseignement à la moindre demande et en
plus il y a dans les grandes plateformes
une cellule du Parti communiste chinois
et dernière chose pour ce qui concerne
la partie occidentale et c'est là qu'on
dit
la menace de la suspension nous nous
disons à Tik Tok vous êtes ils sont
aussi le caïmans ils disent toute la
journée qui sont transparents ouverts
etc leur série de îles Caïmans numéro 2
dans le classement des paradis fiscaux
dans l'opacité etc on ne connaît pas le
capital ou on en connaît certains ce
sont les fonds de pension des fonds
d'investissement américain alors ceux-là
ils les brandissent il les met sur leur
site par contre les les responsables
chinois qui sont là dedans et qui
possède une bonne partie du pays du
capitaine ne sont pas cités et en plus
les droits de vote ne correspondent pas
aux droits aux fractions de capital ce
qui fait que les et notamment le
fondateur Jean gaming a dû faire en 2018
une autocritique publique comme du temps
de Mao c'est tout vis-à-vis des
autorités chinoises est aujourd'hui
celui qui celui qui décide donc une
opacité totale et la quasi certitude que
c'est complètement alors je termine par
là nous leur demandons simplement nous
leur disons et nous disons au
gouvernement français et à la
commissionné vous laissez opérer en
Europe des des et vous êtes vous-même
vous dites vous-même que c'est un
problème d'espionnage et transfert de
données puisque vous l'interdisez à vos
fonctionnaires et le Premier ministre
belge a d'ailleurs dit c'est pour des
raisons de donc vous avez cette société
qui fait comme ça vous interdisez parce
que vous reconnaissez que c'est
dangereux et vous ne pouvez même pas
leur demander il faudra un simple mail
de Paris jusqu'aux îles Caïmans que
demander aux dirigeants de Tik Tok
France
d'envoyer le mail pour qu'on vous donne
la composition du capital et la
composition des droits on a bien compris
on a bien compris cette opacité il y a
encore beaucoup de thèmes notamment sur
les contenus je voudrais qu'on revienne
maintenant au contenu qui sont
disponibles sur Tik Tok je vous propose
d'écouter Chine Labé qui est rédactrice
en chef vice-présidente de newsgard qui
qui lutte contre la désinformation et
elle était aussi auditionnée et devant
la commission d'enquête elle répond à
cette question écoutez bien combien de
temps faut-il à un utilisateur pour
tomber sur des contenus faux ou
trompeurs sur de grands sujets
d'actualité voici sa réponse dans notre
expérience sur les contenus liés au
covid-19 par exemple un garçon
francophone de 13 ans qui a effectué le
test sous surveillance parentale c'est
vu montrer une vidéo satirique sur le
sujet du covid 19 en 17 secondes
seulement après cette connectée à l'App
et 20 minutes plus tard une vidéo le
mettant en garde contre un nouvel ordre
mondial est apparu dans son flux qui
affirmait je cite que la rappeuse
française Keny Arkana avait tout compris
lorsque 10 ans auparavant elle chantait
et je cite encore que les gouvernements
étaient en train de préparer le terreau
hors pair du plus grand génocide juste
pour business
empoisonné et après environ une
demi-heure sur Tik Tok ce jeune
adolescent était exposé quasi
exclusivement à de la més information
sur le sur le covid 19 y compris des
contenus en tuback antivac c'est des
théories du complot anti-gouvernement et
il y a ce chiffre en moyenne il faut 40
minutes pour être confronté à des
informations sur Tik Tok je reviens au
chiffre d'origine les jeunes les 4-18
ans il passe en moyenne 1h47 par jour
chiffre mondiaux donc voilà en 40
minutes on peut être confronté à ce
contenu Nicolas vanbremer comment ça
s'explique est-ce que c'est l'algor de
Tik Tok qui fait remonter des contenus
des informations est-ce que c'est parce
que les utilisateurs partagent plus
souvent des contenus des fake news qui
sont plus frappantes et là on est dans
une mécanique qu'on connaît bien de
rapidité de de transmission de la
désinformation par rapport à la rapidité
de la transmission de d'une info
vérifier comment vous l'analysez ça
alors je pense que c'est pas des gens
qui partagent c'est pas parce qu'on
partage qu'il y a pas de viralité sur
l'individu qui est actuellement de
manière plus traditionnelle sur le web
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est vraiment
plutôt l'algorithme qui va décider de
promouvoir des contenus en fonction de
est-ce que il marche est-ce qu'il
fonctionne est-ce que les gens les
regardent réagissent dessus etc mais
l'individu est peu acteur donc c'est
algorithme et donc c'est assez opaque
c'est assez compliqué mais ça a assisté
d'être étudié il a été voilà et je pense
que aujourd'hui on est au début d'un
chemin d'études et d'apprentissage et on
va avoir une médiation des algorithmes
dans plein de plateformes comme Tik Tok
qui préfigure en fait plein de choses
qu'on va continuer va avoir et donc il
faut les étudier c'est il faut étudier
les effets il faut avoir des capacités
et c'est justement à des éléments qui
est prévu dans le DSA qui permet
qui permet c'est la loi européenne
systémique importante sur les
entreprises comme ça on va se donner des
moyens d'études il faut qu'on ait des
moyens d'études là-dessus important
c'est-à-dire que un une étude de
newsgard j'avais lu un peu les études
qu'ils ont fait c'est c'est un début de
quelque chose mais c'est pas encore
suffisamment solide et scientifique non
plus pour fonder par exemple une censure
ou une interdiction parce que si on veut
appuyer avec le bras lourd d'une censure
sur les médias il faut le faire avec
quand même des indices qui sont assez
costauds et solides et donc je pense
qu'il faut renforcer ces études c'est
important c'est vraiment très important
pour qu'on ait quelque chose permettre
de juger sur pièce ce risque des
informations d'influence dans le débat
public pour qu'on regarde qu'on observe
par des tiers indépendants par des
chercheurs etc et ça je pense que c'est
très important et c'est une des
recommandations moi je suis tout à fait
en ligne avec ça je pense que c'est
assez important
on pourra jamais complètement rentrer
sous le sous la cloche de de cet
algorithme ces euh comme sur l'ensemble
des plateformes est-ce que c'est pire
euh sur Tik Tok dans les autres réseaux
sociaux cette rapidité de confrontation
elle a des informations
à ma connaissance je suis pas sûr qu'il
y ait de chiffres précis sur à quel
moment on arrive quand on est dans une
heure et demie sur un contenu
quand on est sur Twitter ou sur Facebook
on sait que de toute façon c'est un
problème endémique on sait que par
ailleurs c'est instrumentalisé aussi par
des états enfin c'est voilà on a
maintenant quelques quelques années
effectivement de de recul sur le sujet
et on sait que c'est pas si simple en
réalité de lutter contre même par
ailleurs même avec de la bonne volonté
c'est quand même pas c'est quand même
pas toujours évident et que ça a été
l'objet de bras de fer depuis des années
par ailleurs y compris vis-à-vis des
autres réseaux sociaux cette question de
la de la lutte contre la désinformation
du renforcement des équipes de
modération et notamment des équipes de
modération humaine il y a maintenant une
agence étatique dont l'objet est
précisément détecter les ingérences
numériques étrangères donc on voit aussi
on voit aussi qu'on est dans une forme
de progression et c'est vrai que pour
rebondir sur ce que disait à l'instant
Nicolas landremerge moi c'est un des
aspects que je trouve les plus
intéressants dans le dans le Règlement
sur les services numériques c'est cet
obligation qui va être faite ou très
grande plateformes c'est-à-dire celles
qui ont plus de 45 milliards
d'utilisateurs en Europe c'est donc le
cas de Tik Tok comme c'est le cas de de
Facebook ou de Twitter d'étudier les
effets de leurs algorithmes voilà et de
des changements de leurs algorithmes
de s'intéresser aux effets de bord des
changements d'algorithme qui est un truc
qu'on a reproché à d'autres juste sur
les contenus est-ce qu'il y a des
contenus de propagande chinoise enfin
qui présente la Chine sous un jour plus
favorable que peut-être rapidement parce
que on a encore d'autres thèmes à
abordés
des informés c'est douilline comme
toutes les applications chinoises en
Chine vous avez comme tous les gens
en revanche à l'étranger ils sont
beaucoup plus malins que ça ils savent
bien qu'ils sont surveillés ils savaient
que les Américains veulent les interdire
donc actuellement il parle des très très
grandes précautions en revanche
peut-être on aura le temps d'en parler
tout à l'heure mais moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on parle de ce qui me paraît la
principale menace qui n'est pas cela
pour le moment qui sont les transferts
de données pour nourrir l'intelligence
artificielle la guerre de l'intelligence
artificielle entre la Chine et les
États-Unis les chinois sont en train à
travers Tik Tok et d'autres wechat et
autres de nourrir leurs intelligences
artificielles du futur les Américains
d'ailleurs sont en train de faire pareil
mais c'est des sociétés privées qui le
font c'est pas le Parti communiste
chinois et ça c'est comme il y a pas de
grands réseaux sociaux européens et ben
on est battu dans cette gare là et on
donne nos données et on donne nos
données alors ce dont je voudrais parler
parce que là on évoquait ces contenus de
désinformation
auxquels les jeunes utilisateurs sont
des jeunes utilisateurs de Tik Tok sont
confrontés je voudrais qu'on parle de
des effets de ce réseau social sur le
développement cognitif des plus jeunes
grâce à Mathias Arès rebonsoir
Mathias alors que pouvez-vous nous dire
justement sur voilà les effets de Tik
Tok sur le développement cognitif des
plus jeunes alors Thomas je vais faire
remmie une déclaration de Grégoire borse
professeur de psychologie du
développement et de la neuroscience
cognitive de l'éducation à l'Université
Paris Cité lors de son audition par la
commission d'enquête on a très peu de
données sur ce que Tik Tok produit sur
le cerveau en développement avec un
temps de recul extrêmement faible voilà
comme ça c'est dit l'universitaire a été
entendue pendant plus d'une heure il a
fait une véritable distinction entre les
faits dans la plus tendre enfance et
pendant l'adolescence en dessous de 3-4
ans il y a des données qui semblent être
cohérentes et convergentes qui semble
suggérer que ça entraîne non pas des
troubles mais des retards sur
l'acquisition du langage de la
reconnaissance des émotions parfois de
certains types de motricité par exemple
la motricité fine plus tard il y a très
peu de données qui semble suggérer en
tout cas qu'on a un effondrement massif
du développement cognitif de l'enfant et
d'adolescent du fait du temps qu'il
passe devant les écrans le chercheur
réunionce toutefois son propos en
expliquant que le temps d'écran peut
avoir un impact sur le sommeil des
adolescents et donc par conséquent sur
les capacités d'apprentissage il y a des
voies dissonantes sur ce thème oui tous
les spécialistes du développement
cognitif ne s'accordent pas sur les
conséquences de l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux par les plus jeunes
manquent d'inhibition ou de
concentration autant de risques à long
terme que souligne par exemple Irène
Christophori elle est neuroscientifiques
au CNRS et chercheuse à l'Institut des
sciences cognitives
les problèmes principaux je pense ça va
être vraiment pour ces personnes-là
d'être attentif sur les tâches qui
demandent un effort
cognitif donc de la tension soutenue
dans les temps parce qu'effectivement
c'est des
c'est un peu comme entraîner le cerveau
on n'est pas être engagé dans une tâche
cognitive pas être impliquée et pas être
vraiment attentif et puis on l'a évoqué
rapidement dans notre débat les chinois
ils ont tranché ils ont décidé de
restreindre le temps d'écran des enfants
c'est ça depuis septembre 2021 la Chine
a décidé d'imposer une politique stricte
pour les jeunes sur les réseaux sociaux
l'une des mesures phares une limite
d'utilisation de 40 minutes par jour
pour les 14 ans et moins là où les
jeunes européens américains occidentaux
peuvent passer plusieurs heures
autrevier et cela rejoint ce que nous
chercheurs disaient sur le sommeil
l'application est tout simplement
inaccessible entre 22h et 6h du matin là
encore une manière de prévenir
l'utilisation nocturne dernière mesure
celle-ci elle est plus radicale la
plateforme a tout simplement supprimer 7
millions de comptes qu'elle pensait être
appartenir à des enfants de moins de 13
ans un public qui n'est là-bas pas le
bienvenu sur l'application du géant
chinois merci Mathias Claude naluret
est-ce que vous craignez une
crétinisation des enfants Tik Tok
on a entendu au cours de la commission
d'enquête les mots d'addiction les mots
d'abrutissement et puis vous connaissez
le livre
La Fabrique du crétin digital fait par
un spécialiste
oui bien sûr
dans quelle mesure c'est difficile à
dire quel terme employé mais le déficit
d'attention le déficit de croissance
commisive et tout il est vrai sur tous
les réseaux sociaux il est pas vrai que
sur Tik Tok il est probablement plus
voiture que d'abord parce que le public
est beaucoup plus jeune là-bas parce que
l'algorithme est beaucoup plus addictif
et
donc c'est c'est ça qui pose le problème
spécifique du Tik Tok mais tous les
autres sont en train de courir après les
vidéos courtes Instagram
et donc le temps le danger est multiplié
Amal Guiton est-ce que on l'a dit c'est
un réseau addictif est-ce qu'il est plus
addictif que les autres là aussi est-ce
que c'est l'effet de ces vidéos très
courtes est-ce qu'on l'a analysé ça là
pour le coup je pense qu'il y a
effectivement des éléments dans le
rapport de la commission d'enquête qui
qui explique justement le le
l'algorithme et le défilé très rapide
crée ce genre de choses après moi
effectivement je suis toujours un peu je
vivais toujours un peu avec des
pincettes sur cette histoire de
crétinisation mais je relèverai comme le
faisais Claude malurey que effectivement
on facebook aussi aujourd'hui fait des
vidéos courtes qu'on voit que ce format
se développe absolument partout donc
c'est vrai que s'il faut poser la
question de ces formes là il faut y
compris le faire le faire pour tout ça
après est-ce qu'on a pas toujours dit ça
à chaque fois qu'un nouveau média
apparaissait Nicolas Andreas ou est-ce
que effectivement il y a un vrai risque
avec Tik Tok avec ce voilà ce style de
contenu non mais en fait on dit des
choses très spécifiques sur tip-top qui
valent quand même pour beaucoup d'autres
acteurs si j'enlève la partie chinoise
et la partie sécurité qui sont très
spécifiques etc et non voilà mais sur le
reste effectivement on est dans un
mouvement et c'est sué sur lesquels on
travaille sur lequel des régulations
progressent sur lesquelles de des
pouvoir s'exerce sur lequel on observe
ça peut-être pas au rythme exactement
parce que le gendarme est toujours un
petit peu plus lent dans une innovation
voilà où en 5 ans on a quelque chose qui
passe de rien à 150 millions d'Européens
qui s'en occupent tous les jours donc
évidemment ça va vite mais je pense avec
la difficulté de revenir en arrière dans
ce cas-là c'est à dire que quand c'est
rentré à ce point dans les dans les
usages d'une génération par exemple par
défaut en fait vous êtes limité ou à 60
minutes enfin les plateformes évoluent
dans leur dialogue elles se rendent
compte qu'elles ont de l'acceptabilité
tout c'est pas une jungle c'est pas une
jungle il y a la régulation de produits
des effets le dialogue avec les
régulateurs surtout les sujets de
désinformation enfin ça fait depuis on
n'est plus en 2000 à l'élection de Trump
on est plus au moment de Cambridge
Analytica
il y a du contre-pouvoir où on progresse
ensemble je pense qu'on manque de moyens
pour le régulateur notamment pour
l'arcom pharoz pour les gens qui
viennent travailler sur ces sujets et je
pense qu'il faut les renforcer pour
qu'ils viennent travailler et faire du
contre-pouvoir face à cette plateforme
et qu'à la solution ne sera jamais
l'interdiction tion pure et simple
qu'elle ne marche pas et qu'il faut il
faut pas les diaboliser il faut
travailler avec eux il faut les
renforcer il faut les mettre un peu
souple donc là vous êtes sur une mais je
pense vous êtes plus seulement sur Tik
Tok vous êtes sur le le problème
qu'aujourd'hui sur Instagram vous avez
le même chose des vidéos courtes qu'on
scrolle etc de la même manière et le
mouvement va convergeon là-dedans et le
rôle de l'algorithme c'est clair à
chaque fois amalguitant dit intervenir
et oui oui parce c'est effectivement
c'est très juste de rappeler que la
régulation elle a effectivement toujours
un temps de retard et je pense que c'est
un peu incompressible mais quel produit
des effets il suffit de se rappeler ne
serait-ce que le débat sur la modération
des réseaux sociaux au tout début de
Twitter enfin on était dans une espèce
d'affrontement entre la conception de la
liberté d'expression à la on va dire à
l'européenne ou en tout cas la française
et puis le fruit speech américain et on
avait beaucoup de gens disaient mais
enfin Twitter ne fait jamais ce qu'il
faudrait etc il y a un moment où ça
s'ajuste quand même précisément parce
qu'il y a des régulations et ils se
trouvent que en Europe on est plutôt pas
mauvais de ce point de vue là le
règlement général sur la protection des
données la prouver même si il est
difficile à appliquer et y compris il
est difficile à appliquer vis-à-vis
d'autres acteurs qui ne sont pas que Tik
Tok le
digital service is actes le Règlement
sur les sur les services numériques est
à mon sens un bon texte il va être là
aussi compliqué à appliquer parce qu'il
y a des tas de choses où il va falloir y
aller petit à petit et effectivement
étonnant à la Commission européenne
véritablement les moyens de faire son
travail mais c'est là qu'on voit aussi
que on est très bon là dessus tout en
touchant à nos limites c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui on doit se débrouiller avec
d'un côté TikTok et puis de l'autre côté
tout un tas de grands réseaux sociaux
américains bon alors effectivement il y
a la spécificité qui touche à la nature
du régime chinois mais on voit bien que
on est quand même dans des sur tout un
tas de d'éléments il y a des choses qui
se ressemblent en tout cas dans les
dynamiques algorithmiques sur la
question de la localisation des données
aussi et effectivement comme il n'y a
pas d'acteurs européens on se trouve un
peu coincé et c'est aussi la question
des modèles par ailleurs de ces très
grands réseaux très centralisés qui à
mon sens est posée et à laquelle il faut
c'est une question à laquelle il
faudrait se confronter à un moment
Claude est-ce qu'il faut une loi anti
TikTok ou simplement si j'ai bien
compris faire appliquer les les
règlements et les lois françaises
européennes qui existent ça va tellement
vite qu'il faut suivre qu'il faut suivre
le mouvement avant le DSA il y avait le
rgpd c'était la première version elle
est aujourd'hui dépassée
voilà et maintenant vous avez le DSA
mais dans deux ou trois ans vous aurez
le besoin de au niveau européen de
revenir là-dessus et de par exemple il
va se poser le problème est-ce que les
plateformes sont des hébergeurs ou des
éditeurs moi je pense qu'il y a c'est le
système de la responsabilité qui est une
sénatrice ancienne président de la
commission de la culture qui dit il faut
trouver un statut intermédiaire entre
les hébergeurs et des éditeurs parce que
dire que les plateformes sont simplement
des hébergeurs c'est pas vrai quand vous
avez quand vous quand vous gérez ce que
vous produisez que ce que produisent les
internautes à partir d'algorithme vous
prenez des décisions et donc vous avez
une responsabilité éditoriale statut
particulier il faudra que ça évolue
pardon un mot rapide là-dessus avec
cette question justement
et de l'obligation pour les triglords
d'analyser les risques systémiques posés
par les algorithmes quelque chose qui
n'existe que pour ces très grosses cette
question de la responsabilité éditoriale
d'une certaine façon d'un réseau social
on peut se la poser et on se proposer et
le président de la République se l'ai
posé à l'occasion des violences urbaines
écoutez Emmanuel Macron qui nous parle
pas seulement de Tik Tok un des
plateformes et réseaux sociaux en
général
les plateformes et les réseaux sociaux
jouent un rôle considérable dans les
mouvements des derniers jours
nous avons vu sur plusieurs d'entre
elles snapchat et plusieurs autres à la
fois l'organisation de rassemblement
violent se faire mais une forme de
mimétisme de la violence ce qui est chez
les plus jeunes conduite à une forme de
sortie du réel et on a le sentiment
parfois que certains d'entre eux
vivent dans la rue les jeux vidéo qui
les ont intoxiqués Mathieu bien
l'entendre le président qui pointe le
rôle joué par les réseaux sociaux dans
ces dans ces émeutes oui alors difficile
de lui donner tort sur ce point cette
espèce de facteur d'émulation et de
mimétisme qui peut y avoir quand on voit
des contenus qui se passent ailleurs ou
sur la diffusion d'éléments clés comme
la géolocalisation voilà qui comporte
bon nombre de ses applications mais
comme dans d'autres mouvements j'ai
envie de dire je pense aux gilets jaunes
je pense aux manifestations contre les
retraites les réseaux sociaux sont des
outils des vecteurs de mobilisation
précieux pour de lancer les mots d'ordre
en temps réel y compris lors
d'affrontements avec avec les forces de
l'ordre est-ce qu'il faut s'en prendre à
l'outil pour le pour autant ben c'est
toute la question de se débat qui était
sur TikTok mais là sur l'énergie et
c'est assemblée envisager Emmanuel
Macron devant 220 mères réunis à
l'Élysée la semaine dernière il a
expliqué nous avons besoin d'avoir une
réflexion sur l'usage des réseaux
sociaux chez les plus jeunes sur les
interdictions que l'on doit mettre et
quand les choses s'embalent il faut
peut-être se mettre en situation de les
réguler ou de les couper il ne faut
surtout pas le faire à chaud et je me
félicite qu'on n'ait pas eu à le faire a
dit le président alors est-ce que c'est
possible tiens techniquement parlant je
parle de spécialistes mais oui d'autres
pays le fait il y a quelques opérateurs
Orange etc il y a quelques opérateurs et
c'est déjà arrivé d'ailleurs dans
certains circonstances
vous demandez aux opérateurs de de de
bloquer l'accès aussi donc c'est
techniquement pas très compliqué dans
d'autres pays qui sont pas toujours les
plus respectables en matière de droits
de une liberté d'expression pour la
Chine bien sûr mais aussi la Corée du
Nord l'Iran plus près de nous la Turquie
d'erdoine pendant les crises puis la
grande différence vous le disiez Nicolas
va revenir tout à l'heure c'est à dire
qu'on est un État de droit ou il y a des
règles et que on a quand même une
constitution des principes à respecter
alors très vite l'exécutif assemblée
rétropédaler Olivier Véran a parlé de
possible suspension de fonctionnalités
comme la géolocalisation sur certaines
plateformes à certains moments en gros
mais en précisant aussitôt que
l'exécutif souhaitait surtout y
réfléchir et mettre en place un groupe
de travail parlementaire transpatisant
transpartisant pour justement essayer de
faire le point sur cette question couper
les réseaux sociaux ce sera une sorte de
dernier recours quoi et ben coupez les
réseaux sociaux au sens général ce
serait surtout un double aveu d'échec un
échec quand on a l'impression de s'en
prendre au moyen d'avantage qu'au cause
alors là je parle de Tik Tok qu'est-ce
qu'il faut interdire ceux qui sont pas
dans les clous c'est une chose mais
couper les réseaux sociaux quand les
choses s'embalent comme dit le présent
autant couper le téléphone enfin là faut
rappeler qu'Internet les réseaux de
toute façon des outils l'imprimerie fut
un outil le téléphone fut un outil et et
que ça serait voilà faut s'attaquer à
cause du mal et pas et pas à l'outil et
puis un échec ensuite parce que ça
traduit et vous avez vous l'avez dit
bien dit tout à l'heure un rapport de
force très défavorable encore
aujourd'hui au pouvoir public face aux
gérant des réseaux sociaux même si ça
s'améliore même s'il y a des tentatives
de régulation mais on le voit bien avec
encore des petits façades immenses qui
ne font que ce qu'ils veulent alors
s'ils deviennent des éditeurs on le
verra ça changera peut-être les autres
parce qu'ils sont déjà des éditeurs ils
sont capables déjà de censurer des
choses je pensais la nudité par exemple
ils ont décidé que la nudité était
interdite sur certains réseaux sociaux
et là il y a pas de souci ils savent le
faire donc ils pourraient interdire la
violence et pour interdire les contenus
Claude malurey seront nés dans un dans
un vieux et vaste débat rogner sur des
privés de des citoyens de liberté au nom
de la sécurité c'est ça oui alors vous
allez te dire parler des régimes
totalitaires ou dictatoriaux la Chine a
réussi l'Iran la Corée du Nord etc
moi donc sous-entendu est-ce qu'on va
faire est-ce qu'on va arriver à de
telles extrémités pour moi ça ne bouge
pas un quand même énorme parce que tout
ça dans des démocraties et notamment
chez nous c'est sous le contrôle du juge
c'est pas le pouvoir politique c'est pas
le TL c'est pas le dictateur qui va
décider ce qu'on fait c'est si un jour
ou l'autre pour des raisons d'ordre
public pour des raisons pédales
pornographiques ou terrorisme c'est
prévu c'est prévu déjà par la loi ce
sera le juge qui décidera et ça alors on
parlait des meute c'est ça aussi
ça peut commencer à se pas on peut
commencer à se poser la question est-ce
que vous allez faire une cartographie
pour que tout le monde vienne faire la
manif devant c'est c'est au juge de
décider c'est davantage d'être en
démocratie amalguiton et ensuite
l'eau n'est pas Emmanuel Macron soit
celle d'une décision judiciaire
maintenant je que personne ne l'a
compris comme ça et je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui explique le
rétropédalage en règle qui s'est produit
après parce qu'effectivement ça nous
ferait entrer dans un club de pays dont
je pense auquel on n'a pas
particulièrement envie d'appartenir
c'est là qu'on voit qu'effectivement
entre les déclarations à chaud y compris
dont on se demande si elles sont faites
ou pas pour provoquer et puis une
réflexion autour de la question des
algorithmes parce que véritablement
se poser la question de l'effet de ces
algorithmes ça n'est absolument pas
illégitime et c'est pour ça
qu'effectivement à mon sens et je suis
pas la seule à le penser cette question
de l'obligation d'étudier les effets de
bord qui est faite au très grandes
plateformes c'est une avancée la
question effectivement c'est comment ça
va être appliquée est-ce qu'à un moment
donné la Commission européenne qui donc
va être le régulateur en chef de fil va
pouvoir aller vérifier ce qui se passe
sous le capot et le faire respecter ça
c'est mais cette question là elle est
effectivement absolument pas illégitime
mais c'est tout autre chose que de que
d'évoquer la question de la coupure si
il y a effectivement se range revient à
la question de
d'être hébergeur ou éditeur c'est on se
retrouve on réussit à faire évoluer la
loi pour que les réseaux sociaux les
médias sociaux soient en partie
responsable des contenus qu'il propose
est-ce que ça les incitera à être plus
vigilant sur un appel à manifester à les
brûler une mairie ou
s'attaquer à tel ou tel édifice publique
mais ils sont ouais alors si aujourd'hui
ils le font pas ils le font en fait en
réalité et tant que moi pour pour les
pour avoir vu un petit peu comment ça
travaille sans le voir au quotidien
depuis 6 ans environ depuis 6 ans depuis
2016 il y a un travail sur la haine en
ligne sur des informations etc avec des
agences gouvernementales qui travaillent
il y a une collaboration active qui se
renforce tout type qui ne cesse de
progresser qui est pas encore parfaite
mais qui progresse énormément et je
pense qu'il faut la renforcer et elles
sont pas toutes seules là pendant les
émeutes il y a eu un travail quasi
quotidien de toutes les plateformes avec
le gouvernement sur le sujet un bras de
fer une tension mais un travail
un travail contradictoire compliqué ça
les gens Noël barreau c'est d'ailleurs
vanté d'avoir collé une pression de
dingue pour supprimer plein de contenus
c'est quand même un exécutif qui est
assumé dire moi je suis là et j'ai collé
une pression de dingue pour faire de la
censure à bloc sur de l'expression
individuelle c'est quand même c'est que
ça touche à des libertés fondamentales
etc donc c'est des appels au meurtre à
la violence qu'on essaye de les empêcher
mais si c'est pas que ça je pense qu'il
voulait supprimer c'était aussi beaucoup
de choses et voilà et donc cette ligne
elle est je suis tout à fait d'accord
sur la place du juge c'est là que ça
doit ça doit se jouer il doit quand on
est dans l'urgence comment on fait mais
quand on est dans l'urgence comment on
fait et bah il y a il y a d'un état de
droit il y a du jus il y a effectivement
il y a un nombre mais on fait attention
on fait attention aux tentatives
excessive de l'exécutif de d'imposer de
la censure sur tous les contenus et elle
ne s'impose pas elle elle s'agit dans un
état de droit elle se fait avec des
recours potentiels et on a une tentation
de persécutif actuellement d'agir un
petit peu trop là dessus et de sortir le
judiciaire des sujets d'expression
individuelle et c'est une tentative
dangereuse et ce sera notre dernier mot
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat qui était passionnant je vous
dis à bientôt sur sur public c'est là
voilà fin de ce numéro de son suivi que
Mathieu merci beaucoup c'est une super
saison on se retrouve début septembre
pour la saison 3 avec un avec un grand
plaisir vous pouvez retrouver évidemment
tous les programmes de Public Sénat sur
notre site notre plateforme Public Sénat
point et faire et puis l'invité de la
matinale demain c'est Agnès Firma lobodo
ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé belle soirée à
toutes et à tous
[Musique]